ce matin on a voulu vous poser une
question toute simple à la réponse pas
si évident après deux ans de crise
sanitaire comment ça va pour prendre la
vie du bon côté simplement on essaye de
garder le moral monsieur cause de la
situation sanitaire ça nous empêche de
faire pas mal d'activités
quotidien
retrouvez-vous
d'après des sondages réalisés en cette
fin d'année vous êtes 26% a déclaré
ressentir des troubles d'anxiété
généralisée et surtout à faire le lien
entre santé mentale et crise sanitaire
ainsi 33 % des plus de 65 ans considère
que la crise a des conséquences
négatives sur leur santé mentale un
chiffre qui passe à 49 % pour les 35 49
ans
allez
mise au point par une entreprise
suédoise spécialisée dans les implants
un micro puce elle permet à ses
détenteurs de montrer leur cuiller code
s'en sortir leur smartphone de leur
poche autres avantages sont pris une
centaine d'euros
un bracelet connectés coûte en général
le double du prix pourtant un implant
peut se conserver 30 ou 40 ans alors
qu'un bracelet se conservent trois ou
quatre ans hier encore à les refuser la
vaccination chez deux patients qui sont
venus qui ont pris rendez-vous pour et
relax mais ouais et si finalement avant
l'injection autant d'un billet de 2 500
euros carrément et vous dites
aux toilettes
adacore donc en fait là alors qu'ils
étaient dans le box de vaccination ils
vous disent en fait je vous donne des
sous pour que vous fassiez c'est le
fassiez semblant de m'avoir injecter le
vaccin est en fait vous ne mettez à
dubaï quoi c'est magnifique
et ça ça vous arrive davantage ça ça
vous arrive est fière de dire que c'est
donc à nouveau
au moins au moins trois fois oui au
moins trois fois par semaine
et non je trouve ça énorme alors
qu'avant j'avais vraiment que pour des
pâtes vaccinale que pour les pâtes
sanitaire vraiment pas pour le mac faye
avait personne qui loue des cartables et
les médias vous est calée sur les médias
qu'est ce que vous dites là bien
regarder la télévision écouter la radio
d'accord donc en fait dès que j'ai
l'occasion de bar de regarder la
télévision certains disent que c'est pas
très bien mais moi j'aime beaucoup
nantes tandis que c'est pas très bien
c'est des gens qui ont pas le crédit
d'une maison sur le dos
on a beau être animateur un moment il
faut quand même que des gens ne
regardent pas
je suis de là
à c
sommation même en compte est bon mon
comté
[Musique]
fait en vérité c'est que vous êtes un
militant de l'écriture inclusive pas du
tout ici puisque votre mouvement
s'appelle les gens engagés je vous ai
déjà expliqué commencez vous allez vous
êtes filmés même pas vous êtes obsédé je
suis pas mais je suis convié des invités
votre mouvement certaines c'est la
retraire jeu si vous êtes un militant
enlevez vous actionnez sadi fois ça ne
changera rien enfin je suis qui joue ou
non et ma position je suis content même
les engager votre mouvement et écrit en
18 ans vivent chaque enfin c'est quand
même incroyable de ses positions assumer
toutes ces insultes mais il faut surtout
pas répondre pas répondre oui évidemment
je veux pas répondre à tout le monde
mais je sélectionne toujours 4,5 moi je
réponds aux insultes je réponds et je
m'en fous et si le type est injurieux je
le suis deux fois plus je me fous on
doit pas laisser en liberté la bêtise on
doit la combattre la bêtise et s'il faut
la combattre avec les mêmes armes
ignorante que ceux qui la colporte en
premier c'est pas grave je ne
m'abaisserai dans la boue pour aller
chercher tous les ignorants de la terre
en triplettes ya bien
d'autres choses à dire encore cent sept
mille euros c'est notre chiffre du jour
montant auquel s'est vendu aux enchères
cet après midi le tout premier sms au
monde nous vous en parlions hier soir un
joyeux noël merry christmas a envoyé il
ya presque 30 ans en décembre 1992
l'acheteur dont l'identité n'a pas
encore été dévoilé est donc devenu le
propriétaire virtuelle de ce petit
message devenu historique rythme ça vous
laisse dubitatif oui ça m'énerve parce
que je me dis je le sentais gel
centaines de personnes qui nous regarde
sa nature des difficultés financières et
en gach de l'argent comme ça pour des
stupidités bah oui mais sert à rien
france prix ferait mieux de donner
l'argent aux restos du coeur ou oui
c'est une façon de voir effectivement
des choses mais acheté une toile est ce
que ça c'est la classe et le ferrand au
moins aller chez vous et qu'elle restera
alors que la halle de sms je sais pas
combien de temps il va durer c'est
l'excitation dans un bar tabac près de
manchester
ces deux britanniques viennent de gagner
quatre millions et demi d'euros un jeu
de grattage c'est en tout cas ce qu'il
croit lorsqu'il fait l'événement et
diffuse ses photos en ligne mais au
moment de récupérer leurs gains à la
loterie nationale s'aperçoit qu'aucun
n'a de compte en banque et que le ticket
gagnant a été acheté avec une carte
volée regardez ça on prend une fusée on
la met dans une espèce de château d'eau
on met de l'eau sous pression de l'upa
du lot à à 250 degrés à l'intérieur et
cette eau à 250 degrés après bon on va
la faire sortir par des tuyères et la
fusée va pouvoir décoller exactement
comme une fusée traditionnel sauf que là
est bien c'est de la vapeur d'eau qui dé
grossesse c'est pas du tout les gaz
toxiques on a l'habitude d'avoir donc
c'est le même principe que la fusée
traditionnel ce qu'on fait avec sommes
comme des enfants comme un film
catastrophe où tout est réel dans la
ville de mayfield aux états unis l'écran
de cette salle de cinéma a été arraché
par la tornade qui s'est abattue sur le
kentucky il y a dix jours
depuis les sièges qui ont résisté on
aperçoit l'étendue des dégâts à travers
un trou béant me alors est-ce qu'elle
pollue beaucoup les fusées les plus
accueilli énormément en un petit chiffre
pour vous montrer par exemple parler de
liesse et de du milliardaire kit année
dans l'ue tandis ss un voyage à lies
s1500 1150 pardon tonnes de co2 et c'est
l'équivalent de six cent trente huit ans
d'une voiture qui roule drake un smic km
par envoyer ses c'est considérable et
d'en parler d'émissions de co2 mais il
ya aussi des gaz toxiques mais ma fuite
je suis hyper v n'est en fait je ne
connais pas personnellement alors je
suis hyper gêné je n'ai jamais fait ça
de ma vie alors là tu veux dire bonjour
je suis même pas y arriver et toi garde
man
d'avoir moi j'ai demandé nos pigeons et
consentent orange tient à préciser
m
[Musique]